leaders are confident there will be a
game at 1 pm at allegiance stadium on
sunday afternoon
now kovid 19 concerns they are still
present but there is belief they'll have
everyone back by the important start of
the game
john treach has the very latest at a
story that john really is changing every
single day sometimes by the hour
that's right brian every world-saving
apocalyptic movie has the scene where
will smith
walks down the abandoned road with a
smoking and crumbling city behind him
that's john gruden forging forward with
the game plan despite a roster on fire
with uncertainty and
a healthy buccaneers team waiting to
pray on the week
on wednesday lyman trent brown was
placed on the reserve coveted list and
the entire offensive line was sent home
in a cloud of caution
crisis seemed inevitable the league
moved the buccaneers game out of the
sunday night television slot
expecting a postponement derek carr
called it the weirdest thing he's seen
and this is coming from a guy who played
with antonio brown
but the raiders have continued to plow
forward with replacement players and
now are confident everyone except brown
and quarantine defensive fact jonathan
abram
will be available
at one o'clock they tell me and we'll be
ready to go it's like having these
virtual press conferences
you can still get a lot of work done uh
so we've had good week of practice and
uh
like i said we'll be ready to go well we
played uh four games without trent we've
used four different right tackles so
we're experienced adjusting and
we'll have a right tackle that's
prepared and ready to play and the good
news is
when i have talked to trent he is
feeling better and
hopefully we get him back here soon he's
a big part of this team
also worth mentioning the buccaneers
have the most dominant defense in the
world in the greatest quarterback of all
time coming to las vegas on a hot streak
but let's not get bogged down in details
of preparation and practice time
the raiders have 45 hours to get enough
guys to feel the team